nous sommes avec joaquim pueyo maire ps
d'alençon et jean-marc chipeau porte
parole debout la france bonsoir
messieurs jeu pour commencer je voudrais
vous faire réagir aux propos du leader
de la france ont soumis jean luc
mélenchon sur les réseaux sociaux il a
appelé ses sympathisants à la prudence
pour je cite qu'il ne soit pas confondue
avec des termes que la france insoumise
jugent inapproprié car l'extension du
passani terre est sous le feu des
critiques comparé à une mesures
dictatoriales certains commentaires ni
même le vaccin et la shoah jean bart qui
a chip au porte parole debout la france
elles sont mesurées
ces critiques selon vous tout ce qui est
excessif est insignifiant c'est ce que
disait talleyrand donc il faut être bien
évidemment se garder de partir dans des
comparaisons qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
bien évidemment c'est pas la shoah c'est
une c'est une évidence n'a pas même pas
le préciser pour autant les déclarations
d' emmanuel macron lundi soir ont été
d'une violence inouïe à l'encontre de la
moitié des français 6 à 30 millions de
français qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
lundi soir et on s'est adressé à eux en
les stigmatisant en les jetant en pâture
à la vindicte populaire en les rendant
responsables et traitant d'irresponsable
et en lettres et en les rendant
responsables de la progression du virus
ça par contre c'est sont des excès de
langage aussi que dans le président de
république devrait se sentir bien
joaquim pueyo avec ces comparaisons on
constate en tout cas que les annonces
des manuels mâcon ne passe pas vous vous
comprenez vous ces critiques
évidemment surtout sur les critiques de
dictature on peut pas comparer avec ce
qui s'est passé pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est inacceptable de
faire ce genre de comparaison je pense
que le président m'a cran ou déterminée
effectivement à lutter contre
l'extension de cette tendinite
je crois qu'il a pris ses décisions
c'est parce que j'effectue mans à la
variante prend de l'ampleur actuellement
moi seul et je suis maire d'une ville
président une commune et urbaines et
satee comme très compliqué pour pour les
collectivités locales de gérer les
services lorsque le matin
apprenez gâtant personnes qui sont
attendus qu'au vie qu'il faut faire mais
tel service au lac du mal à mettre en
place et cantines scolaires donc
concrètement ça a été très compliqué et
moi je suis un élu qui souhaite que les
français à se faire vacciner massivement
alors c'est vrai que c'est peut-être dur
en termes de planification ne l'a
peut-être pu souhaiter un peu plus de
temps que de mettre en oeuvre
immédiatement effectivement les mesures
mais moi ça me paraît quand même
nécessaires à moyen terme parce que je
vois effectivement les conséquences sur
le terrain
et puis malgré tout il ya trois semaines
un mois dans les centres de vaccination
on avait des possibilités de vacciner
les personnes qui se désistait y avait
des taux ce qui est des ligues chaque
soir depuis l'annonde du président macro
on s'aperçoit que les français ont pris
conscience que c'était nécessaire
aujourd'hui huit cent mille personnes se
sont fait vacciner et je pense qu'une
majorité de français moi j'écoute sur le
terrain les habitants de ma vie de la
communauté urbaine je suis également
conseiller départemental est globalement
une majorité sont favorables à ce que
vient d'annoncer le présent arrêt public
donc moi je pars attaquer le
gouvernement parce que souvent on
habille saisissez là ils ont pris une
décision peut-être difficile
effectivement à mettre en oeuvre
je pense aux soignants qui devront se
faire vacciner à partir du 1er septembre
peut-être que le délai un peu court mais
c'est nécessaire si on veut vraiment
retrouver une vie normale à la fin de
l'année parce que s'il ne fait rien si
on laisse les choses aller
eh bien on aura une quatrième bague il
faudra encore faire des compliments et
je peux vous assurer que sur le terrain
pour les pour l'économie pour les
services c'est très complexe et très
difficile depuis lundi
je ne pense pas ça manque dictature une
décision qui est prise d'ailleurs on
peut remarquer d'ailleurs pas que la
france il ya des pays qui manquent ils
prennent des mesures si vous sortez de
la france pour aller nos interurbain il
faut deux passes annie terre soit la
vaccination soit le texte pcr de moins
de 48 heures en effet la chapelle hardin
effraction se sent plus en étant plus
traire ajouté moi j'écoute les médecins
j'écoutais scientifique et une majorité
de médecins
sont favorables pour que la vaccination
soit un peu plus importante au niveau de
nos concitoyens voilà moi j'écoute des
médecins également autour de moi les
scientifiques et l'académie de médecine
est également favorable voilà maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on peut se poser des
questions sur les libertés publiques
tête à notre débat des batchs de devoir
certainement au niveau des parlements
vous les personnes qui se sont fait
vacciner aujourd'hui depuis lundi on
peut dire que les français se sont rués
en sûrs d'obtenir pour obtenir une
première injection en fait aujourd'hui
on en est à quasiment 880 me injection
c'est olivier ferrand qui l'a annoncé
tout à l'heure on est à presque 4
millions de primo vaccinés depuis lundi
sa rivale quoi pour vous jean-marc
chipeau que les français ont compris
l'importance de se faire vacciner ou
alors qu'ils se disent bon de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix il que la
question est tout à fait quel choix
ont-ils on les prive de tout on les ans
on va les empêcher d'aller travailler on
va les empêcher de prendre le train on
va les empêcher d'aller se ravitailler
dans les centres commerciaux pourraient
les empêcher d'aller à la pharmacie dans
des centres commerciaux et même des
questions il y avait un article dans
nice matin aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on va admettre à l'hôpital dé
des patients qui n'auront pas leur pass
sanitaire vous vous rendez compte
jusqu'où ça va enfin c'est une je pense
qu'on ne réalise pas les français
aujourd'hui sont saisis de stupeur ils
n'ont pas le choix des options ils sont
condamnés par leur président à devoir
faire ses armes et pardon moi je peux
très bien en tant qu' on ait besoin de
temps pour vacciner la population et il
faut vacciner les personnes fragiles
mais si on veut s'acheter du temps vous
pensez pas qu emmanuel macron qu'à la
chasse de la france aurait pas pu
prendre des mesures en amont
moi je l'avais dans le dans le sud de la
france suis allé la semaine dernière
chez leurs d'espagne j'ai pris
l'autoroute a9
je suis sortie à la plage ou nogueira
alors j'entends les sourires des larmes
que c'est la première sortie derrière la
frontière
je suis revenue de l'autre côté j'ai pas
vu un douanier
j'ai pas vu un policier on avait tous
des qr code dans la famille il y avait
des vagues dans la voiture il y avait
des vaccinés il y avait des noms
vacciner tout le monde et est en règle
on a vu deux personnes la semaine
d'avant j'ai fait exactement la même
chose en italie
si vous voulez vous acheter du temps
vous avez un variant dont vous savez
qu'il arrive de l'étranger parce que le
variant indien delta c'est invariant ont
vraiment indien jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il vient pas de
clermont-ferrand ou quimper
la moindre des choses c'est que lorsque
vous êtes en responsabilité vous
commencez par contrôler vos frontières
ça sera pas parfait ça se fera pas
étanche vous ne réglerez pas tous les
problèmes avec ça mais vous vous acheter
du temps pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique que vous promouvez ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième fois qu'elle
aime quel est le problème majeur des
manuels macron aujourd'hui vous avez une
note qui est sorti de de l'institut
pasteur c'est un peu d'ailleurs là où il
prend tout c'est toutes ces sources
emmanuel macron en ce moment je voulais
lire cette note parce que l'architecturé
elle vous décidez dynamique de
croissance du variant delta se poursuit
au même rythme la pression sur l'hôpital
pourrait devenir important dès le mois
d'août d'un moment où les hôpitaux
risquent d'avoir du mal à accueillir des
patients
voilà c'est ça la raison principale
c'est parce que l'hôpital est dans un
état absolument désastreux aujourd'hui
c'est pas uniquement la faute d'
emmanuel macron il faut lui reconnaître
c'est une tendance lourde depuis chirac
sauf qu'on continue à fermer des lits
les hôpitaux dans le nord de paris vont
encore bichat beaujon et rythmes
wazières encore perdre 20% glee est le
problème il est là c'est qu'on ne sait
pas on ne sait plus accueillir les ans
et plus actuel et accueillir les malades
par joaquim pueyo est ce que vous êtes
d'accord et ce qu'on n'a pas fait assez
au niveau du contrôle des frontières et
ce qu'on n'aurait pas lieu plutôt mettre
l'argent dans dans les hôpitaux sur le
contrôle des frontières je suis d'accord
avec nos collègues parce
qu'effectivement je crois qu'il faut
davantage contrôler les frontières ont
tellement serré au port c'est lui les
témoignages par lequel il est très peu
de contrôle absolument renforcer les
contrôles comme certains pays le sont
d'ailleurs
deuxièmement je suis d'accord aussi le
les hôpitaux on a laissé tomber les
autos notamment dans les villes moyennes
il est grand temps de se ressaisir et de
renforcer effectivement le nombre de
lits dans les hôpitaux n'est une grande
métropole comme des villes moyennes
et là il ya un déficit mais qui date
depuis 20 ans depuis 20 ans donc ça
c'est nécessaire mais la 2ème et la 3ème
observation je voulais faire
actuellement selon les informations que
j'ai pu obtenir
sur ceux qui attrapent le commises
actuellement la variante 80 ou 16 % de
ceux qui sont vaccinées n'attrape pas
c'est donc ce qui démontre bien et ça je
je voudrais vraiment avoir la certitude
c'est que le vaccin tel qu'il est
actuellement que ce soit ce troisième
tome preiser empêche le la variante de
se développer donc c'est important de
savoir que la vaccination est efficace
mais dont vous savez moi j'entends
effectivement certains j'ai lu certains
citoyens de dire on est content la
vaccination
oui mais la liberté est elle également
mise en cause par rapport à ceux qui
veulent vivre normalement qui se font
vacciner
donc moi je pense qu'il ya des
vaccinations obligatoires on n'a pas
rendu obligatoire mais c'est vrai
qu'avec les mesures ont été prises on
incite fortement les français à se faire
vacciner mais après tous ces pauvres
protection au niveau de la santé si
c'est pour mieux vivre et c'est pour
vivre en toute liberté dans quelques
mois ça vaut le coup quand même sur tel
que moi de faire des efforts la loi
d'urgence et se termine le 31 décembre
moi j'espère que cette loi va pas être
renouvelé et puis je fais confiance
également à mes collègues parlementaires
j'étais le député encore quelques mois
pour que le projet de loi soit amendée
peut-être au niveau de la panification
niveau du temps je pense
qu'effectivement mais délais sont très
courts
j'en conviens mais même malgré tout le
fait de dire
la vaccination est nécessaire et
indispensable si on veut effectivement
eu évacuer ce que vides
on verra d'ailleurs qu'il faudra une
troisième partie nations sera peut-être
ce genre vacciner une fois par an comme
pour la grippe dans les années qui vont
venir mais ça me paraît nécessaire parce
que actuellement quand même souverain
sur le terrain souffre énormément pour
l'accession sur le sagittaire parce
qu'on parle beaucoup du magic usagers
sens mais il ya aussi ma test besser les
personnes les personnes âgées sont fait
vacciner énormément les jeunes ont eu du
mal à franchir le cas là ils sont en
train de faire donc moi j'encourage tous
les jeunes à se faire vacciner pour
qu'il prenne une vie normale dans le
sport dhr dans la culture dans les
activités économiques jeunes un point de
plus mais - français - d'accord final la
coordination terrain sur le terrain je
dois gérer je dois gérer des espaces
culturels
page sportif et l'espace économique
également je vois les difficultés
lorsque j'ai effectivement il ya des
personnes qui sont soit contact qui
attrape le coc vite ça détruit ça
déstabilise nos services c'est donc
ventilation tests pcr avec l'extension
de ce pass annie terre on le rappelle
pas assez souvent mais on est forcément
dans l'apathie nation jean marc flipo je
vous laisse réagir finalement sur ce que
dit et joaquim pueyo
est-ce qu'on n'est pas obligé de passer
par là pour retrouver notre liberté à
retrouver une vie normale surtout
combien de fois qu'on vous propose ça
parce que jusqu'à présent
alors donnez moi les français ont été
exemplaires
les français on leur a dit mettez pas de
masse qu'ils ont pas mis de masse on
leur dit mettez un masque qui en ont
besoin
on leur a dit ne vous faites pas testés
sont pas fêter ça lors du fait de vous
tester son fait tester
maintenant on leur dit vous pouvez
toujours vous faire tester mais vous
allez payer ah bon très bien les
français ont été exemplaires et pardon
mais on n'a jamais nous là debout la
france
il n'agit jamais été anti vaccins jamais
jamais à aucun moment bien évidemment
les vaccins sont sont utiles lorsque
vous rentrez dans une dans un ratio
bénéfice risque les personnes à risque
ont tout intérêt à se faire vacciner
mais je remarque d'ailleurs à ce sujet
que le gouvernement a opté comme
d'habitude de manière totalement
arbitraire pour une vaccination
progressif sur le seul critère de l'âge
mais vous aviez le docteur tiers des cas
pas plus tard qu'en début de semaine qui
vous disait que en début de cette
semaine justement la moitié des obèses
n'avaient pas été vaccinés
qu'est ce que c'est que cette politique
sanitaire qui laisse des personnes en co
morbidités quand des risques avérés de
contracter la maladie qui la laisse sur
le bas côté de la route larron considère
peut-être que ces personnes ne sent rien
je sais pas ils sont pas importantes
et pardon est ce qu'on peut avoir une
politique sanitaire qui soit complète
qui marche sur deux jambes pour
lesquelles vous aider un vaccin pour les
personnes qui ont des risques de
contracter la maladie parce que oui
s'est avéré le vaccin front ne sommes
pas contre le vaccin a des effets qu'on
ne connaît pas il ya des autorisations
encore des mises sur le marché
conditionnel et le président de la
république n'a pas le droit d'obliger
les français à se vacciner lors tant
qu'il n'y a pas une autorisation de mise
sur le marché définitive il le sait
s'ils pensaient qu'il triche on vous
avez des traitements à mettre en place
vous avez le séquençage à mettre en
place vous avez des lits à ouvrir vous
avez une réserve sanitaire a organisé
vous avez tout un tas de soins à mettre
en oeuvre
je constate avec joie d'ailleurs
l'institut pasteur a enfin donné raison
à aux 32 étude randomisée qui avait eu
lieu sur l'île et réactive qui
permettent de soulager les symptômes
voilà énormément de choses assez lourd
disait merci pour toutes vos prestations
merci pour votre analyse jean-marc
chipeau malheureusement on manque de
temps à jean marc flipo porté parole
debout la france et merci à vous aussi
joaquim pueyo maire ps d'alliance